okay I should be live and back after a
couple days of not streaming I've been a
bit sick still a little sick but at
least now I can talk hopefully so I'm
gonna play the no I have to join the
tournament I forgot to join
I think I joined in time
okay we're gonna play ten-minute chests
let's play I don't know what to play
well start with a London if he lets me
yeah push back for hello - Bora kya roll
thanks for being the first commenter
yeah e6 and c5 so we're transposing and
perhaps some more mainline after a minor
three and in this position I like to
play a tricky move Knight c3 ideas of
playing d5 also ideas of playing back b5
hello to the gamer ooh okay t5 is a
blunder cuz might be five just wins wins
everything
but best move for black was he take d4
not d5 uh yeah this is a nice trap in
the London which actually not too many
people know about like c3 is a pretty
rare move and now he'll probably just
cry
realizing there's two way to stop night
c7 I guess you could play e5 but then
they take e5 there's still issues uh
yeah hello two more people
hello Jennifer to Africa cool guy Yanni
of KZ
just in time to see the first the first
game yeah one bit about this opening
after I played my next move to c3 I
think for anyone who plays a sign up is
black and you don't know it to to
against Knight c3 I think it's best to
take and after you take Bishop b4 and
it's playable for both sides but Queen
a5 doesn't solve anything might c7 is
still coming
at age five okay
considering bishops
but then b6
see southern
stuff can get traded the very least I'll
win the exchange
time for him to win the night I assume
he's going to play like King d8 and
we'll trade on f4 hello it's a smelter
good to see you back
proud of your last game
ah
yeah I would like to see her game
was it a London opening if it was a
London I would like to see it even more
it's hard to get the London that and
every team though
unless your whites
so we're trading more my nights together
I guess I'll just take
in trading dozens doesn't really hurt me
I don't mind to simplify
trying to think like how he's gonna win
the nights so if I can save the night
that I'll just be up a rook
not the easiest piece to save if he lets
me I'll probably play Bishop b5
even some of like beef or chase away the
Queen
um for the time being I'm going to turn
off challenges because I won't be
accepting any challenges as long as I'm
playing in this tournament so I'll just
do this real quick
privacy never sorry people who are
challenging me
maybe I'll accept challenges if I'm
alive after this tournament what we'll
see it's a two hour long tournament so I
don't know if I'll get through this
tournament can i play b4 here is before
win more material I take before
Ponte P for Queens AP for than humans
and nights
or I can take on c6 and then play b4
that looks decent
I'll gather couple pawns but ok I'm
winning the bishop
you go over how to be d4 c6 way d4 c6
Knight f3 d5 Bishop f4 it's a good line
for white I can't find a solid Vantage
I'm prepping for someone
um
so basically London against some kind of
Slav setup
what does Queen okay Queenie for this is
a bit annoying because I don't want to
give away g2 if I play like Queen III he
comes back to b4
yes I can't get everything that I want
I have to make a choice between playing
vishuddhi 2 or maybe like Queen III
Queen B for King D 1
or King d1 here even the King d1 here
Queen a for that's actually kind of
annoying
calculate queen III queen before king d1
Queen a4
I could play king Siwon
then there's no more checks I'm ready to
play some rugby one move
that's okay
you
his queen is not enough to cause me
issues like he would need to bring in
his bishop in his rook but he's so slow
in doing so
and in the meantime I'm up a rook in and
Knights
or two pods
you
yeah to answer smelters question
I would recommend delaying III
you
I do have to be careful with Koine for
Queen be 3d without Queen D for winning
the rook have to watch out for Forks
um
okay so here's what I can say to
Schroeder after d4 c69 3d5 Bishop f4
well it depends what black does because
if black plays
okay if black play is one of the main
ideas of the line Queen b6 you can
usually sack the b-pawn you can play
might be d2 queen take B 2 and e 4 and
that's one key variation but if I if I
get through this tournament and I'm
still streaming asked me later because
then I can go through it in some kind of
analysis board but hello to more people
good to see there's more new viewers on
the animator gym TV
um I'm always happy to play the London
system toilet noggin is back ooh maybe
I'll have to play an exchange right just
in honor of toilet noggin
Jacob Utley hello
I guess I could have played Bishop e2 in
queenside castle
maybe that would have been strong
because in his queen would have been out
of the play but I like this position
um he's probably gonna play something
like this
and then okay hole win the night but
I'll be up and rock
I would like to play Queen b3
I have to make sure f4 is defended
looking at Bishop e7 York b1 bishop take
a 8
I think there's any immediate kill but
okay d4 I think makes life easier
now I can okay we're either trading
Queens or yes to retreats
then I'll develop my Bishop and be happy
when is my next tournament I actually
don't know
I just finished playing a couple events
in Europe so okay let's have standings
turn done
oh yeah I don't know when my next ribbon
is I might play some some side events in
st. Louis like during sink [ __ ] up
I think they usually have like a uplet's
or blockhouse treatment
his queen is being annoying
kindiy ones phone
I'm drinking tea Oh what couple what
kind of see am i drinking
okay so I'll show this because I think
it suits the stream title pretty well I
went shopping today and I bought this
tea as chess pieces on it I have no idea
I think it's some sort of like black tea
but it was like screaming to be to be
bought so hopefully it's good for my
chess
what rating is a my system book aimed at
I actually can't answer that I have not
read my system I think it's aimed at
like just general there's a pretty big
range of players be like
want to give a range but okay I won this
game back to tournament uh okay some
people are ahead of me who berserk
Wendy 94 has already played two games
uh yeah I'm recovering from a cold if
anyone watched my last stream I was
suffering at the end of it so I took a
break for two days
okay let's play what do I want to play
let's play e5
we'll take opening suggestions - ooh
Kings gambit
I play in schemes
let's play something weird let's play 96
I usually play d5 well I'll play this
variation f5 Nakamura played this once
again sieve on junk and then he lost
the sky seems somewhat well-prepared
but okay and this is a completely new
opening for me because I'm out of
preparation after Aoife or after f5 I
assume I can take with this pawn and
then win a five
looks Pleasant maybe white will play g4
go for it
this just looks good for black he's
playing so quickly
we e2 so he wants
play d3 but now he is blocking in this
Bishop there's usually not that great
for whites the most natural move here is
Bishop c5 in castling but that could
potentially run into queen c4 check so I
have to be a bit careful with how I
develop leaning towards Bishop d6 and
then if he plays d3 I can just castle if
he takes twice on e4 or three times on
e4 I would have rook e8 in the end so in
the queen
um I guess other option is Bishop b4 but
that could still run into queen c4 stuff
so I'll play this
because if you plays d3 and then I
Castle
the opening of the the e-file will favor
me because his Queen and King are just
kind of stuck in the center
I'll take so you're going to take on e4
that is that he sees rocky yet but
is already like I think really bad for
whites okay Bishop III is reasonable
because now he wants to Castle queenside
but it's my move
like this where you're heading
development you want to look for ways to
just seize initiative I mean I could
just win upon and prevent white from
castling
also considering Queen h4 check C as
bishop f2 that I can take on f4
one idea is g3 queen s6 I'm attacking
the rook and the b2 pod
you
we play queen f2 then we trade
I'm winning pawns
he plays Bishop g2 doesn't work okay oh
wait a minute he still has Queen c4
check ideas so if I play like Queen h4
g3 and Queen f6 Oh Queen c4 bishop d5
okay I think I can go for that line
and something's gonna fall there's so
many targets the King pawn other pawns
rook a pawn
he's not going to defend everything
yeah so this is one light I I calculated
and just assumed that I could take and
play rook e8 pin the bishop
me too but I'll play rookie eights
threatening Bishop F or Bishop to c5 he
probably has to play kini - or King King
F - now I can start taking stuff
this is Pleasence winning some ponds ooh
I really want to take
is it rook tag I win the wreck if King
take
bishop
also don't want to overthink this
King tech rookie a check in f2 Bishop c5
King f1r than Queen B 5
okay I think this is working Brooke take
III King take III rookie AIDS
f3
as if king of to Bishop c5 okay this has
to be good
is also king d2 but then Bishop before
of king d3
Wien b5
more line to calculate tick tick
you
oh there's also a queen c3 check
and if king of two it's simpler because
here
I'm confusing myself
I mean there's honestly no need to go
for this I can just take on c2 and be up
a couple pawns
okay I'm not gonna confuse myself I'm
just take on c2 not gonna be fancy yeah
let's just simplify I'm gonna be very
boring just simplify and get this game
over with I haven't really been looking
at the chats I'm sorry about that
a delayed counter Cabot's I was just in
a lane like six months ago
six months ago maybe eight months ago
okay I'm just going to take
you
looks good enough
ooh
okay well now I think I'm trapping the
bishop because I have b6 in rec AIDS
plus he's somehow tricky he's in the
player like rook d2 or something and
then go for Bishop take b6 which is a
little bit annoying
but then I can win the a to pawn okay
or just trading
I'll win on a two with check and I'll
take Rick see - and it's should be an
easy conversion - connected passers
make sure is king king cat
active play rook c5 this is a nice
prophylactic move and then I'll just
start pushing the beep on
you
you
you
some weird line rook be a jerk b5 we
trade okay never mind
what is going on
I could play rook see to rook see -
looks nice
I need checks and d7 okay I'll start
with like some useful King move
clicking e6
just improve the king
ever plays this side can trade rooks she
plays this he's just passive
you
pushing
you
this endgame technique not the best
technique but getting the job done I
think you can't take on B 3 because c4
hey I'm in a rock
okay
it took a while that was an interesting
opening
at first I thought he was in crap but I
think he was just trying to I don't know
what he was doing is playing a bit too
quickly yeah it's an interesting Kings
gambit line at five I think it's pretty
rare but it's playable back to
tournament
hello messy Marvin I have not been
looking at the chat I see I see the
message for messy Marvin
thanks for the sub
Clio 294 I assume its polio and not
Paulo
um but correct me if I'm wrong
I have not been looking at stream
notifications but thank you to anyone
who have been following or subbing I've
just been so focused on chess and I'm
behind in the behind
Colorado blunder buzzer King and winning
the game
okay thanks to the people who followed
findable chicken
mangu bang
some names I can't pronounce
listing
you
I'll scroll up and try and see if I owe
my gosh there's so many there's so many
questions can i play some Karel Khan
today
by Jennifer - I could pre-move c6
caro-kann okay d5
okay devoting this game - Jennifer - if
I lose some I'm just blaming on Jennifer
-
um I usually don't take Carole cone
but I'm gonna play the sign with Knight
f6 I think it's a it's supposed to be a
solid variation
you
late one night c6 against efore it's
playable
Arsen has been playing it recently
okay now I'm a bit conflicted because I
I think both moves are playable you take
f6 is far more common but I'm going to
make things sign that mic up I'll take
with the Jeep on as it gives me a G file
I guess I can start with raqchi AIDS
and try and discourage white from
castling kingside
you
and at this point I'm probably just
improvising a queen d5 I think is some
idea let's play Queen g5 are the way
feels a bit wrong because I'm developing
my major pieces before my minor pieces
but
it's interesting
you might play g3 Bishop g2 but I have
Bishop g4 Bishop g4 is coming pretty
soon or Bishop f5
you
here's some question about this bishop
what to do with it
maybe I've ideas like Bishop g4 or Queen
h5 and Bishop h6 trade-off the darks for
bishops lost are three six nine thanks
for the sub me reconfigure my window so
I can see notifications there we go
okay so he plays Queen d2 he might want
the castle but a2 at hang so I'll play
this
maybe he'll play c4
stipe gizmo thanks for the follow
yeah I'm just trying to apply some
pressure
and just complete development 296
tonight King ahead but 97 should be
coming I forgot I allowed him to play
Bishop e2 because I no longer attacking
a jeep on
let's just play 97 see what he does is
whichever way he castles okay he can't
Castle queenside right away but wherever
his King goes I can try and attack
debating here between Queen f5 and Queen
h5
you
looks weird but I'm going to play
queen-size
you
maybe it's the wrong choice see I want
to play Knight b6 ad put a rock on Yeats
also targets c4
who's the best player I've ever played
I played Carlson in soccer and
basketball but not in chess
eh five because g4 it's a bit sad so I
have to take yeah this is probably
slightly worse for black his white has a
bishop hair now and more space
but I get Knight b6 in
tackle upon
whoa you just give me the c4 pun
that's a free pawn unless I'm missing
something
I don't think I'm missing something take
can you take on c6
that might be annoying I've queen bee
five
yeah let's take
White's probably going to get some kind
of
session
how about Queen before I can take on e3
if he takes on b7 it will be interesting
please take on b7 no okay
klonda - made him uncie -
well now I could queenside castle that
runs into Bishop g4 by Queen d7 but that
runs into this
so what do I do
queen bee five losses upon
to play rugby aids
or I could calculate Queen d7 because it
can get interesting after something like
c5 and he can't take on c5 Bishop h6
coming
okay I'll play this
I manage my time a little bit
Gabriel Thomas Newton thanks for the
follow toilet noggin is eating okay
enjoy your food
you
you
you
weird position but I'm I'm feeling okay
here
debating east six probably not necessary
of age six looks interesting
it's pressure the pawn
you
I feel like box pawns should be on light
squares just because of this obstacle or
Bischoff situation
go ahead and play east six and then
probably at five
then it comes with tempo
thanks for the follow Attila or attea
665
you
you
you
yeah I just have to manage time Wow I've
won I've only won two games so far so
many people are ahead of me I might have
to up the pace somehow some way okay
maybe now I can Castle queenside
you
and we'll just have some position where
I'm up upon
good evening from Swansea
where is Swansea I think I've heard of
that before
Super Stallion good to see you back
watching pretty often
you
or a possum or a raccoon am I losing a
pod
that move
wait I don't think I'm losing a pond but
maybe I am Brooke g6 this could get
really weird
Bishop h5 or cure
g4
okay go for some weird stuff we'll see
if he's brave enough to take on h7
I don't think I would be brave enough
you
you
Bishop h5 would be oh wow
grave
okay so rook h6 queen g8 I have some
discovery I could also play Bishop h6
right away yes to defend the pawn
you
what to do
you
have some idea of Bishop h6 Bishop g5
work h6
start with this
I want to see how he defends upon
it's not the easiest part to defend he
does this I could do this
he does this and he has less pressure on
the F file
if he does that
lazeric a few 1
I trap the queen
so they're still coming
you
looking at this move
than this
not sure if it works so
you
you
very strange position
also just play this
getting low on time I should probably
move
you
some crazy idea like Queen here here and
then taking
too slow though
you
okay this is not the move I want to play
but I think it's in a solid move Bishop
g7
it has a sneaky threat to it makes sure
that if he plays Bishop h5 he's not
winning f7
and we'll see what he does now I really
gotta manage my time two minutes
there's no increments now it's equal
material
you
very suitable playoff five
and something like Bishop f6
my queen probably wants to maneuver
somewhere better
you
I'm gonna play much quicker
you
I have some half-open files on the
kingside
sure if it's an easy to exploit but
maybe something like rocket shades at
some points
g4 but unexpected
I can take
g4 is a good move
you
you
now we want to play f5
kick away the bishop make sure that he
can't pressure that file too much before
interesting
in the Queen to e7
key threats
you
Long John Silver thinks will follow
yeah
so the one of the main goals is to play
quickly and come back a bit on time he
still has an annoying time advantage
whoa that's a good move
she's probably playing beats Oh also a
sevens attacked Wow very strong move
okay so I'm worse on time I'm worse in
position but anything can happen
you
what he's thinking
do this trade Queens is gonna win the e6
pawn
we'll get some weird endgame
you
you
good thing is there's optical your
bishops so there's drawing chances
there's also still winning chances these
positions can be very deceiving
of course black is still much worse
now I want to do this
we're this
you
you
you
you
still down on time down upon
this is tough
g1
good thing is my bishop
the controlling a cheats which is one of
his Queens worse
Karrueche one
you
I can do this
one
a time is almost about level
this preventable
in the pond
I made him somehow work a ch3 and then
some weird stuff
you see for a six
frightening meets how does he stop it
wait he's in some kind of pickle here
this cake is completely stuck this rook
can moves kind of
I'm just going to keep waiting
untangles
you
hmm I don't want to draw this I actually
want to play for a win
wait he's just giving me a pause he'll
take that so now I'm playing for a win
you
okay he's being tricky that's a good
move actually
what do I do okay let's do this
you
I'm finally up on time it's a miracle
you
oversee for
those bishops how to play Brooke here is
coming walking with my king
mmm throw in the check
you
you
you
you
yeah I'm on the verge of winning
or just flagging him okay I was
stressful
somehow I won that probably not
deserving but that's the nature of chess
yeah I probably just played some dubious
opening between each worlds good move
I probably took too long around here and
then yeah this endgame it's uh it looks
pretty grim until until I came back
okay back to tournaments I'm sorry if I
think of the chat
[Music]
funny animator Jin TV says hurry I was
hurrying I know
you
to come a plays finally call the stream
nice um okay well I'm I'm not doing not
great in the tournament I'm top ten on
the man TG thanks for the follow I'm
gonna play of London oh I forgot to play
AE for me I'll do that next time
I'm 82 place III
ninety-two
in 1992 thanks for the follow if I
missed anything important than the chats
feel free to repeat yourself
fever monkey
said good evening like a while ago okay
Queen d7 playing Knight f3 I think ideas
of 95 but 95 is really strong here right
any theory but it looks like a good move
as if he takes and that I take and then
he moves and I and I had the should be
five
McWhorter thanks for the follow wait no
that's an S snack or
small font is tricky to read
okay so I assume he's going to play this
yeah now
can I just take tick tick I'm threatened
the night and threatening this I'll be
winning two parts
we'll win upon back
I'm just going to trust my intuition
found out missing anything
but I don't see how he defends both
threats
probably have to do something like this
and that I take
and at the very least I'll be up upon
with a good position
you
whoo
it's interesting move
it wants to take on g2
Stardust 16x thanks for the follow
I could play f3
the truth
I could take oh I could take and then if
he takes on g2 I've worked g1 the skewer
please take on g2
jeez
I mean whatever he does the positions
gonna be good for whites he takes back
I'll play this
I wonder if he's watching might be
watching and just realizing my ideas
just going to trade
wait a minute
this could be pretty powerful bye
Felisha
b5 enforcing Bishop c6 and then rook t1
he has to play this
I would like to leave the tension
or build up pressure somehow
you
what to do okay good position let's not
overthink
I'm just going to castle
ever plays rook g8 I can I have many
ways to the Fen g2 f3 or bishop g3
so he wants to castle
like to play rook teafork without runs
into this so I'm going to start with
Bishop g3
now I have ideas of just doubling up
I also have ideas of this pinning the
bishop to the Queen and the bishop would
be pinned in two directions
and maybe I I combined rook see foreign
Queen a4 okay he really wants to play h4
but do I care
I don't think I care Roxy for Bishop e5
Bishop e5 right away
let's could get a bit weird with rook
c4h for Bishop e5 or just Bishop f4
of f/4 okay
you
or the g3 instead of weight fat Brad
what if instead of g3 you went h7 I
don't understand this
instead of Bishop g3i I don't think I
understand that maybe he's saying Bishop
h6 maybe it was a possible move okay so
you play as h4 Bishop e5 is tempting but
then f6 here e5
I'll just do this
you
you
why all of my black plastic have it
Bishop d6 oh wow
okay hello Joshua
to see you Joshua each three
I kind of have to play g3
looks ugly maybe I could just play Queen
a 4 if you take Sanji to rook d1
you
now this is a problem with the bishop
being pinned in so many different
directions if he takes on b5 I take the
Queen with a check and meanwhile running
this or this
so blacks in trouble
ship t6 aggressive mission t6 is too
aggressive
you
I have a question Armond mods are
allowed to approve comments rights this
should be
allowed to like ban comment or block
users or I don't know okay I'm gonna
play rook t1 my king is super safe this
pawn gives me a shelter
and with rook t1 I control the D file so
whoa he castles well now Bishop h6 is
some idea
probably just take first
I'm conflicted I want to meet him I also
want to win the c6 pawn
maybe just winning c6 and then where is
this queen going
like have a queen bee seven rook c7
he's going to play Queen f3 lyrics
defended
they win the bishop
trade okay I'm winning the bishop
what was my rating after a year of
playing I could look that up go ahead
and look that up I'm going to my website
to go to my profile
and then after a year of playing
we're going to take the bishop
is it one through 50
so I started in 2001 so I think it was
around
about 1200 I think after a year
take the rock and play rookie AIDS
those kings in trouble
but like my first year of playing chess
like I was really into it I got a coach
pretty early on
and I was a kid so I just learned I had
looking things are the quicker rates
okay where's the meat
check
not going to calculate I'm just gonna
keep checking until it's made
you
to keep checking
you
this is good enough
okay that was a feel-good game what did
he do wrong yeah he fell for some I
don't know if this is theory or not but
95 seems like a problem for black I
think usually black is supposed to play
queen c8 to avoid this 95 type move back
to tournaments Colorado blunder loss but
he's still in first place way he lost a
link he lost looks like he drew a game
and very far behind
but I'm slow and steady
and reach and ask lost a game
sometimes a strategy with these
tournaments is just play as many games
as possible in berserk every game which
isn't my strategy
uh we'll see if slow and steady can
actually work out
hopefully I get to play pick one of
these these top players
uh what's a play let's play a Sicilian
I played caro-kann thank you Matt f8 for
the follow be for I studied this opening
recently because I thought I was gonna
run into it in a tournament I think the
best sign is to take and play d5 whoa
five is this
looks suspicious
I haven't committed to e6 I can develop
the bishop
what to do lady for where is interesting
play b3
I just want to get a position where I
know all right where my piece is want to
go
think about these lines of white like
take some please t4 c3 the center is
very solid
for right away doesn't seem right
okay I'll play Bishop a5 looks like a
normal move if we get some French
structure I want my dishes outside of
the pawn chain
I'm actually threatening some kind of
funny double attack with this
which see he just walk into this
you
looks interesting
I don't think he can defend both things
he does have that move in the smooth
you
it's a good sign he's thinking because
he's out of any like opening preparation
not so chess I like me not to berserk I
don't think I'm gonna bidder I like my
time to think so a queen takes you to oh
that he takes here I have to take with
King
looks reasonable
Trading Queens I think
you might get cup but it looks like a
position
okay let's retreats
yeah White's gonna have compensation
here like the half-open a file is gonna
be annoying this pin will be annoying
developing the kingside will be annoying
do you have a pod
and probably the path for development is
e six I attacked the pawn he'd probably
someday played Bishop t2 and then bring
the knight in
by a six here a six is a nice move too
they can decide what to do with the
bishop because in some cases he would
like to create this pin reserve the
bishop
the bay 4 okay
so if I play B 5v5 is probably a blunder
cuz Bishop b3 then he has a double
threat against both pawns
I have Knight b6 defending defending
maybe b5 as possible
you
there any rush so if I play this first
she plays this I take
except tonight that's knowing
so e 6 P 5 by P 6
Stephens
I'll start with e6
I just want to see what he does
on the Castle queenside grand eggplants
castling queenside okay maybe it's
playable but it's just I'm a my king
would that be a target on the C file
normally the king would like to say the
center
I would like to bring these pieces into
the game as quickly as possible
okay so do I need to
that's a bit slow
the problem with b5 is it creates a long
term backward pawn on e6
I can do this in this business
okay
I kind of like that plan
you
is that my bishop can find a home on
some square
sometimes it's an issue with this e
seven squared because both the bishop
and the knight want to access it
58 is that he can't invade with any rook
c7 now all these squares are controlled
so he could control the open file but he
can't really penetrates
I'm doing a good job so it's all about
87 well thank you appreciate the support
it's it's very difficult sometimes to
actually play decent quality chess and
interact with entire chats
also asking or also answering questions
I might just have to do a separate
stream to answer questions
like scrolling up here I just see so
many questions it's difficult to answer
everything
okay so my original ideas might be six
attacking the bishop
I also play a 5-2 try and close things
down
but let's calculate 96
if he takes I take the bitter p2x here I
play this
and yeah everything's under control
and if he plays Bishop b3
Bishop c2
could be a bit annoying so maybe I just
buy a five a five hunting B 6
if he plays b6 himself I just take it
and he can't access b1 because my bishop
on a side of such a good piece
play night b5 so here here take 95
that's a bit annoying
sigh Bishop d3 here
just like kind of Intermezzo or just
like counter-attacking move I don't
think he has time to do anything on the
queenside he has to play Ricky one
and I could even
maybe that I go for that line
I'm gonna start with Bishop d3 forgot
about that move and something I should
have just considered much earlier
expecting this
and then a 5 e six
86 and the differences might be five I
can just take it
very much coupons
and then 97 86
you
you
still kind of want to take
okay I'll go for this
there's a movement I forgot about which
I'm not going to say
he might be watching
yeah
about this night f-for move I will think
it's a huge issue
so I have Bishop c4
is okay Bishop c4 take take
and ip6
in some cases
yeah there's not too much time to think
so it's gonna trust my intuition
he's got in compensation though my pawns
are kind of weak
so I'm gonna do this so he stops me
ah that's actually a very strong move
yeah this is not gonna be easy I could
actually be worse here
maybe g5
chase away the night
or 97 right away if I take on me six
here's Rick b1 so
okay this is very uncomfortable try and
survive
the pen is so annoying oh really
interesting
if I take his six
this is not pleasant
okay this take take
take take
mm anything else
I don't think I can take and allow you
six
okay
try and survive
he's been resourceful
I'm still up upon mother pond is keeping
all the tension
I can't castle G sevens hanging
seven I mean he takes and plays east six
oh maybe rotate
he also wants to take on a five of the
positions was falling apart and I'm low
on time
what to do
maybe a four
doing something
you
okay
so he has a six if he wants
you
or not
I'd see five maybe
at least it's some active move
these squares could be nice
controlling e6
I'm situation it's equal material
such a weird position
a six I guess
ah this is hanging
what to do
yeah chess is tough
which I even do here play this
time situations so bad
now upon but I have nights
disrepair he wants to do this
let's take
you
you
oh this is so bad
so strong especially combined with a
passed pawn
this is really bad
don't kill me
that's a good move
to do
you
you
you
groans you got counterplay it's not
really working though
you
while Bishop c4 is giving me some hope
should still be completely winning for
whites but I don't think Bishop c4 was
necessary
you
I have hope now I've
second so not too much hope
I think he's trying to play on time
maybe the one thing
I can give me hope if you put if he
tries to flag me and then plays bad
moves
I want to take on you seven
you
you
you
that's not good
this is really not good whoa what is
this
four seconds left what to do
you
I'm trying to fight
as difficult
and some blockade
you
on the light squares
please just repeat
you
Oh
or still hate me that would be nice
please still meet me it's not still me
it's no unfortunate it got weird
oh my god it's getting some counterplay
the bishop on b2
fantasizing about night c1 but probably
never had a chance to work also he had
rook c8 here rook da and then take take
f7 would win yes tough game
is a Fisher trap any good I don't know
what the Fisher trap is I'd have to
explain
yeah maybe Bishop d3 was a bad move
because my left for but he was getting
counterplay I think I underestimated his
uh his compensation t5 so resourceful
if I have like one more move
to play knight c6 it's still complicated
though
okay back to tournaments chess is tough
this is really tough I'm in 13th place
their one loss I think I lost a lot of
rating points too
okay let's try and come back I'll play
e4
is something different than the London
I could play b4 let's play a knight c3
Sicilian
one of my favorite openings play Grand
Prix attack
a spa 99
it's going okay this is tough prevent b5
let's prevent d5
you
I just want to castle
you
is doing some unusual move order
I'll play Queen e1 this very common idea
this sort of opening
III
I'll try and move quicker compared to
previous games the play bishop
b3 or Bishop a2
play bishop a two idea being that if he
plays g5 I can respond right away with E
5
I'm King each one
and then Bishop b1 so this is uh okay it
looks unusual but the long-term idea is
to play this and then this and then this
and then this and then each seven will
someday be attacked by my bishop
see if this is actually doable
well it might be happening a five
it's gonna happen cuz im gonna play c3
d4 and he can't stop it
um Bhaiji for
my bishop is so well placed on b1 now
you
um it's really hard to keep up with the
chats uh pass upon 99 when you get paid
next week you're buying the whole DVD
nice I would recommend by the by the
digital download is it's essentially the
same thing don't buy the physical DVD I
guess you could if you want but yeah
for anyone who's uh
like it for anyone who's bought the
course or is interested by the course
and you have questions just let me know
Queen g3
Queen g3 looks decent
so just play a ch3 right h6 and g4
so many tempting choices
by g5
okay
I also play f5 f5 actually looks very
enticing as he can't take because I take
with bishop
five this is why it's important so like
to cycle through candidate moves you
might see one move like initially I saw
Queen G 3 it looks good but then I saw
other options like h3 but I finally saw
f5 which i think is the strongest
there's now I want to play h3 after
Knight each six I can take it with the
pollen s6 is looking nice
Oh for anyone who's interested in buying
the chorus
I can share a link which gives you I
think 50% off
at some point I'll probably do a
promotional stream but there's a link if
anyone's interested
h6 now or h3 now and this is this is
almost just over
is the night strapped yesterday yeah
to this
calculate tick tick I have f6 right away
tried to find the winning
after take take f6 Bishop here queen g3
King h8 it's so close to winning
how do I beat
all I need to do is attack h7 maybe
Knight g5 there
five than Queens III
you can't defend h7 okay let's do one
more cycle of calculation bishop take h6
pawn take h6 I guess he could sack on f6
but let's say Bishop I fades here here
Knight g5 I'm threatening out 7 h7 so he
would take and then I played Queen d3
and my queen bishop battery is too
strong okay
you
you
you
maybe he'll think here
always feels good so I calculate and
then play all the moves of the
calculation
I'm sure there are other ways to win but
this looks like the most straightforward
I don't think you can stop queen bee
queen to d3
because there's so few resources to
defend h7 nice game
I think that was a nice demonstration of
king of the Grand Prix this idea of uh
it's so unusual to put the bishop on be
one where it's essentially behind the
pawn gene but then to very soon just
push all the parts worked out nicely
okay back to turn
is it detecting my stream
because it should say oh it is detecting
my stream okay it was interesting I'll
play another efore game playing so no
toto one
never play them before
recently rated rapid player
do I play against you
I'm trying to think of some opening I'll
just play oh I'll play an exchange Roy
hopefully toilet noggin is somewhere on
this planet playing the exchange Roy uh
but let's treat it a bit differently I'm
gonna play b3 here I just want to get a
fresh position I know this is a playable
move
um probably not the most theoretical but
playable
that's with Chris I have no idea how
they decide what names on the tournament
page and on the front page
are they featuring my stream it should
be a better be
hey they are let's play Bishop b2
yeah I think they have some like system
where if you stream for a certain amount
of consistency then they'll start
putting you on the front page
uh okay I'll play d3 go for this typical
Spanish Knight maneuver let me bring the
93
also considering some idea like that h4
but in this sort of structure the f5
square could be very nice for a light
nights
bathing about move order
okay I'll start with this ooh he wants
to come to f4
you
so it's a battle between who can access
is f4 and f5 squares I could very easily
play g3 this completely restrict is
Knight
he's going to play 96
gee three anyway
as if he plays ninety-six and I'll play
my h4
maybe he'll play g6 whoa I was not
expecting that the first thing that came
to mind is my TIGI v queen h5
but his knight is defended by the bishop
but maybe there's some ideas
okay maybe I'll just do this
this is interesting and I want the plane
there are five in Queen h5 I also just
want to play queen h5 immediately and if
he plays g6 maybe I could still play
that r5
because I win the night this pawn
structure gets a little messed up
take on f2
take back
betrayed
let's do it
please try and make him think
the funny thing is if he plays Bishop f8
I was going to say I would have to move
back but maybe I don't
we go just leave my bag about five
and his name is weird
I don't know if I want to take on d6 is
it about doing anything
okay chip d7
play a four keep all the tension trying
to discourage b5
some idea here to play a five and the
night see for where my night would be a
rock and that he could he would have a
very hard time saying be five
now 87 having so much fun it's good to
hear
I don't know if I'm having as much fun
just because chess is stressful but I'm
still enjoying it how can i play this by
g5 and then h4
86 h5 here f4 stuff is happening let's
do it
so many pills this is pinned and this is
pinned
chess is so confusing I'm going to play
h4
I think
quite has some King side attack
like all these pieces and two nights the
Queen and the rook
potential especially because h5 is a
looming pawn break
you
if you take some as late as pinned
I was expecting one of these moves
and then I play this is this
whoa
I forgot about h5 I don't think h5 is a
good move just because it looks
weakening
I do
you
wait a minute oh no I didn't miss
anything
Wan fook gee thanks for the Sun at first
I thought I could take and then 9 8 6
meat but my bishop is blocked by this
pawn ok
some kind of
a weird hallucination there
I think I have to play Queenie too I
don't think there's any reason to think
we need to
thanks for the sub J Schulman sedid so
many subs I haven't seen one Fuji in a
while
I haven't been streaming for four - too
much - recently
uh but yeah it's good to be back
so now my night is kind of actually
attacked I would like to play G fort
without a last night f4
have to take the bishop
no I don't want to yes I don't have to
what else do I do work g1
I could just go completely insane
one orgy for you can clean up three
you
94 is annoying in many lives
it's shut thanks for the follow
if four possibilities
okay I'm gonna combine ideas I'm gonna
play rook g1
it's a piece sack this would probably
calculate
that's just a bad line for whites
I'm gonna take the bishop we're not
gonna sack apiece but I'm gonna try and
prepare f4
try and bust open some files
I guess I'm allowing 94
I decided between taking at Queen T 1
um a five check forgot about that move
as king of fun
you
my king is safe on that phone I'd like
to play Knight c4
just gotta manage my time
I really can't believe I'm actually
almost making it until the end of this
tournament but my showing has not been
great given that
I've I joined at the very beginning of
the tournament I've won all but one game
not even in top ten
look like queen d1
if I want to take I can do so anytime
I might want to play c3
uh-oh I forgot about this move
about that move thankfully I've night g2
it could be a bit annoying
it could be very annoying
so my king should probably if I get the
chance should be on this square
probably miss Bishop h3
play Kingi - thanks for the follow
Clinton Levin
and feingold has only been mentioned
once in the stream so far well now he's
been mentioned twice
do I take 85
shop here
what to do
this is just a bad position
you
my knife belongs on g5
how to get there
this is ad position I could take on that
five maybe
it's with bishop I take we trade a bunch
of things these bishops e6 never mind
I could play c3
that his latest moves back
okay let's play c3 need to move faster
thanks for more follows four more people
the Giacometti
I think one of the ideas is that if he
plays a night here I can take and we're
actually just trading and I'll reroute
my bishop to this diagonal
and probably put the Queen on e to
Bishop on e3 mmm this looks playable
nothing too tragic yet
you
I'll play rook Athlon these are the play
rook aphids
come to g5
or h6
maybe Bishop h6 and then Bishop g5
you
you
oh wait do I have Bishop f4 here
Bishop f4 and his rook is trapped you
would probably take
take care
like Queenie for
no I can't play Queenie focuses hangs
okay I'm gonna start with rook t1
Bishop a4 is the idea I have to keep in
mind
um start with this
how can i play
spawn with him
okay I'll play rook d2
keep things defended now qui for that
still loses upon
but maybe it's necessary
Oh what to do you play Brooks no I can't
play Roxie water
you
looking for counterplay
not seeing too much
time I'm tired
so difficult
but what does he throw there I'm gonna
play Queen d1 and just wait and try and
move faster I think the plan is to bring
the rook to e4
he wants to maneuvers
but here play another five oh my gosh I
just missed
that should take you seven
but is this a queen trap
[Music]
gosh wait what's going on I think he
could have taken on g3 with the rook
I'm so confused right now I just want a
piece which is nice
but it's not over because I have less
than a minute I should have taken a nice
a turn and just one material like a
different way but okay g5 is coming also
my palm is attacked
found everything I could play a g4 maybe
actually kind of a nice smooth cousin
Bishop g3
solves both problems at once
you
okay 34 seconds
quicker
you
you
ah
really annoying
really really annoying
even Julian's us
by just losing
well I could take wait there's still
hope by 14 seconds
debating King H King g8 King h8
I'll have more chances to meet him
that was a bad move was really bad
enough
you
okay I think I'm going to lose this game
but I'm still gonna try in the face
kind of
hey I'm winning a rook
oh this is bad
this is really bad
you
you
I made him maybe these
you
you
if only I had more time I think this
would be hole double for a draw
kind of
ah that was a good move
no good game oh well the disappointing
game I liked my position at some points
until I didn't like it and then I just
got no one time should I turn off my
volume let me mute this tab let's go
back I think there is just one simple
moment I was playing like the one moment
I played too quickly
was after he played 97
can just take the night
analysis board
take the night and then this rook is
overworked hey can I win this
otherwise this should be an easier win
and then something weird happened
because I played rookie for
oh maybe I was scared of rook take g3
for a split second
but then after take taking each one
[Music]
this is still probably good for whites
so what happened take here
yeah the H file
you found the right plan I should have
put the rook on each one
it's tough to find these things with low
time who is this I SOG been watching on
YouTube there's time catching a stream
nice I think that's a lot of people at
least recently this is like my my
previous stream is that I upload to
YouTube people watch and then discover
me via YouTube then follow me on Twitch
I do so many people play with no
increments
yeah I mean most of the arena's don't
have increments and it's one of those
things it kind of teaches you how to
manage your time except I have I haven't
been taught that fully yet aft on thanks
for the follow as our time left in the
tournament is it over
oh there's 13 minutes left maybe I have
time for one more game
it's where that's not detecting my
stream it should be
it's on the homepage
was very strange
I wonder if it if it shows up for other
people or it's just me
idea
well maybe I can finish in top 20
as possible
okay last game hey I'm playing Colorado
blunder who's the first seed let's try
and take this seriously
he's buzzer King and he's playing h4 I'm
gonna play over versed London because my
favorite opening
ah let's ignore what he's doing let's
also try and get some rating points back
with this game yeah I'm just gonna play
a London nothing special
oh my gosh and I already plundered a
piece you serious
ah this is really a trap
blunder apiece on move for
this is disgusting Bishop G 6 H 5 should
be was this
this is really really sad
you
I I feel disrespected
so I mean there's ways to get
counterplay if Bishop g3 in some
positions
it's not that bad
Hertz
I should provoke f3
okay let's provoke f3
sir nuo thanks for the sub
Bishop e7 and Bishop d6
you
or Bishop g6
or nine f6
as for the options
kind of trying to 9s six
you
okay I mean look like they have six
maybe not the best option but let's try
and play quickly here I might have to
rely on time
now let's play Bishop e7 is going to
play g5 I play h6
that's a good move
he's still kind of having some problems
because I can take here
and then maybe play f5
I also have night that would be weird
let's play our five first
he is 9f for
you
because this is gonna get really weird
laughter a9f for I'm gonna play King d7
this is very similar
Pond
play a six because I want to play c5
but maybe I should drop the bishop back
first
let's drop the bishop back
oh and maybe I can just play c5 right
away and very soon
as like b5 I can play night seats
you
okay let's develop
what a position
see three
King c7 like Keaton c7 then do some
artificial castling
Queeny seven
probably Queen d7
someday I want to play you five
whiskey Brown thanks for the follow
you'll donate
if I win with under promotion okay
challenge accepted
okay I want to do this
you
it's always flaking be it
positions very solid I love my pawn
structure
it's not
we don't want to trade
okay I'll just defend with the Queen
the rook there
dark light and one thanks for the follow
kimby it
I'm up on time and I used to being up on
time g6 is weak
okay I want to play e5 but is it too
soon
okay I have one connect for
over defend upon
maybe rookie six
because I might want to do this and win
that hard
but smart trade Queens
I just want to keep the game going for a
long time
you
mm he wants to play Bishop h3
you'll play this
getting off the diagonal
someday I'll do this
and do this because I want to do this in
this
and it's going to play rock a one
you
I think it's time to go for a four
because g3 is a potential penetration
point where after the trade I have 95 93
get messy though
let's have this move
you
problem is a5 is so weak I might as
pinned to the rook
you
it's not an easy position
so 95
one
thanks for the host Pepe
were people to be watching me though
about to lose to this guy
okay I'm looking at 95 and Queenie
eighths
hoping for some sort of counterplay
let's do it
you
I don't think this is going to end well
but what else to do
okay
93
or other night moves some other night
moves
like c4
it's a cheer from Nathan thanks for the
bits
I'm officially low on time down on time
what am i doing
you
okay let's go for a 93 it's an outpost
stuff is pinned
I think my position is just [ __ ]
completely falling apart
you
oh but I have might be five in some
positions let's try this in might be
five
I defend the rook
and maybe I have some cheapo sacks
things work but he's running mates on a
fade-out
either way defend he's also threatening
my rook yes I could take everything's
attacked
so sad
take
[Music]
what to do
you
searching for ideas
not saying much
oh wait a minute I could take here and
take the night
because then Rock FA rook e8 because my
queen down defends that's something
you
much
queen bee five
you
you
we still have an outpost though
never resign when you have an outpost
okay let's play this
in it
she's threatening this made and this may
what do I do
here please take my rook these
he's just toying around with me okay I
resign that was really painful he
deserts me he played a 4h for he trapped
me on move for G for what a trap keep
this in mind
London trap
this makes me wonder
like uh analysis porn and someone just
refute the London by playing
imagine h5 here
b6 III
now this would be a trap
next person I play who I know plays the
London I'm gonna try this just to see
what happens
as a decoration I was a pretty good
looking decoration though
was a clutch resign
okay well
is b5 good here in all-caps b5 is
sometimes good
maybe yeah maybe the
the stream thing hides
know how the leech as streaming
detection system works anyway uh
hopefully I was instructed for people I
was a bit painful I lost a lot of games
which okay I probably deserves to lose
some of those games but I think a
combination of lack of time management
maybe talking too much and overthinking
uh yeah chess is tough I have no pending
challenges because people are not
allowed to challenge me um which is okay
I'll I'll change that privacy always
there you go refresh
such good interface saves automatically
back to turn its back to homepage
hey thanks for the follow rioni 86 so
yeah if you're watching are you just
joined
um oh my gosh so many people are
challenging me now I continue the stream
I just played two hours of chess
I think I'm going to end the stream
I need to recover
maybe next time I'll do a Q&A stream so
many people ask questions which I feel
bad about getting too
but I was a bit preoccupied Nathan with
the thousand bits
I was unexpected thanks Nathan
oh that's a big cheer yeah I really
drink some more of my chest tea I showed
this at the beginning of the stream but
this is my my new tea
I had to buy it I hope it doesn't have
caffeine
I can't read check
maybe we'll read this
people can read this
affin
some translation ya viewer challenges
will probably have to wait until another
time but maybe we can play this guy
toilet noggin 100 bits thank you we're
gonna pay play Pepe because he he hosted
me or he raided me he challenged me to a
one-minute chess960 so hopefully it will
end on a good note
good luck Pepe
let's just castle with the follow
opening principles
maybe we can Castle queenside yeah wait
this is bad already
let's push pods oh my gosh
this is really bad
okay I wanted to end on a good note
I see six it's not too bad
okay this is my final game I don't think
I'm accepting anything after this
taken that this someday I'll win this
pond
day oh my gosh I'm losing the exchange
okay
I'm low on time I'm down on time
he's putting all my pawns
good move
okay the fight back here
you
okay the c-pod avoid Queen trades always
play a five maybe I can take on c2
someday draw King a7
you
you
oh no he's mating me no he made it me
think thankfully that was casual didn't
lose any rating points okay well I lied
about ending on a good note
always play a five when Feingold has
said that right
oh I don't think he's ever said that
okay
good job Pepe
pepé played strong
see okay Pepe are you okay if I call you
Pepe
or should I say Pepe Lu Pepe is easier
to say a bad mood Kanye thanks for the
follow
okay I'm gonna end it here thanks guys
for watching and good bye